the og of the OC Vicki Gunvalson stepped
out in LA on Thursday to celebrate more
than a decade of The Real Housewives of
Orange County the reality show returns
to Bravo for its 11th season on Monday
it's gonna be a great season I love it
Vicki stunned in a bright red dress the
perfect color for a woman in love she
attended the event with her new beau
Steve Lodge a politician and former
police officer now is tonight date night
for you yes I brought my date and he
brought his daughter and her boyfriend
so we're like having a little family you
then tonight's fun that's freaky to
introduce him to the world of housewives
because he didn't know about it before
so no it's good it's very good the 54
year old hasn't been shy about her new
relationship she's posted plenty of
sweet snaps with her man on Instagram
clearly Vicki is an open book which she
says is her approach to reality TV I
just be me and be real and be authentic
I just love being the part of the whole
franchise it's just a great great fun
ride so